foreign
yeah
one second
so
um okay so uh I will kick us off and
then Philip will take it
uh uh we'll take it and
dive deeper into you know our
presentation so
um
but essentially uh uh we weren't sure
about the structure or what type of
audience we would have like would it be
more technical we would we be talking
more about the business side of things
so uh or the data side of things or the
python side of things and so and so so
we're gonna prepare a quick
um overview about
um exactly what we do uh in people logic
um you know and then uh
how we do it with python briefly talk
about how we do it in Python and why uh
python in those uh scenarios
um
so first off uh talking about uh people
logic
um
you know I feel like you can probably
move to the next slide yeah so
um what is uh
people logic is essentially
um or in a nutshell is it called people
intelligence platform
uh what it means is
um or the goal here is that it's a tool
to help
managers and our organizations as a
whole to serve their employees in a way
so
um you know uh
uh you know understand the tradition uh
engagement levels and so on so
um
and help
teams and
um
and are in the organization to uh be
more
productive in a way but uh not uh so
it's not about productivity it's more
about organization health and team
health and burnout braids making sure
everyone is happy and Everyone likes
working with each other and there's no
like uh disconnected folks and uh or
folks
on the brink of uh burning out and
showing the table
so
um so just very brief intro about uh how
this Arts actually started uh after Matt
uh the CEO that uh
Andrew was talking earlier about having
met him but um
so this started after Matt and me uh our
our last startup uh it kind of grew to
be uh you know a really toxic place as
you know as investors uh started uh
coming in and um you know and eventually
even got partially sold
um
so it grew into a bit of a toxic place
to work on
um so
we kind of wanted to try to help others
prevent that from happening as they grow
like as they go out of this uh you know
startup phase where uh everything is uh
is rainbows and everyone is very happy
and engaged and into uh you know
um that more um so as a yard from that
surface and you're looking more
uh become a more grown-up company and
that's when things sent me
become a bit toxic uh the company is
based in Durham
um but the whole engineering team is
based in Portugal as INR
uh natural Portuguese citizen living in
Portugal and it made sense since I'm one
of the co-founders and I'm a CTO uh for
me it made sense that the engineering
team was closer to me so so we have here
Philippe and I think you also have
another representative here I think
Teresa is also here
um listening to to this
so on to the brother so uh basically uh
we have like three main
um components of the product uh the
first one is uh what you called graph
which is commonly known as an
um I guess Ona or organization network
analysis so essentially
um
essentially the way to see how teams
organically organize uh themselves so
like uh how people are connected which
groups can are formed uh organically uh
who works well together who is
disconnected from the team and so on so
it's a sort of a way to view
um
the team and look looking at the team in
the organization so uh it's sort of
comparable to you know kind of walking
around in an open office and uh
checking out how folks are kind of
huddling up like trying to solve
specific problems or you know uh you
know who is kind of working on this
particular project and so on so it's
like
um
that view that you don't have like uh
um since everyone's remote now so now
it's like uh so we're kind of trying to
provide that view from a remote
environment
um the other component uh is what we
call Safe actor so it's uh it's
essentially a metric it's a measurement
of uh engagement uh or I guess how how
willing are folks to stick around uh in
the company so um
and uh I guess I I like to to look at it
in uh as kind of uh
performance metric but reverse so it's
more about how is your uh company and
your manager performing in your relation
to you as an employee so if you're happy
in your uh
of course this is very subjective but
the idea is to uh you know try to
understand if you're
engaging happy with uh with your current
role or current responsibilities or if
you're in the brink of uh you know
burning out or um
or or you know potentially uh starting
to look for other jobs
um and then we have
recommendations uh which
um you know are essentially the drill
down version of the state Factor uh
pretty much so essentially or more this
more concrete insights
um and recommendations around your team
and your organization
and what provides the actual like these
early warning you know someone is uh
is again on the brink of pouring out or
is is in need of a provocation or or um
you know is completely disconnected from
the team or you know we think uh they
might not be happy or just completely
um
you know using a
using a common uh
uh expression disease
I guess
um
so yeah so then uh so this is kind of
hypnologic in a nutshell
um and you can probably move
to the next
click uh and yeah and this is just
essentially our uh we we are so I'm
gonna just probably make yeah probably
this should have been the first slide
but yeah
um so essentially I am yeah I am
hernania I think I already mentioned
this video people logic
um I did not write this intro uh
otherwise that wouldn't be so humble I
guess but uh yeah uh but I'm uh not
originally a data guy uh I'm more of a
generalist in essence
um data guy here is Philippe uh but I I
was a python guy uh uh a while back I
was actually involved in a
previously the popular but now kind of
defunct well not kind of like completely
different open source project in Python
for a few years
um
and then I was completely disconnected
from python professionally at least for
a while and now it's sort of sneaked in
back uh as uh your natural choice for
some stuff we do
um
and then we have lip uh he has a kind of
real star here uh the man
uh men can make a sense of everyone's
ramblings and make and put that into I
guess concrete data analysis and
algorithms and so on
um if I'm actually about a few years ago
actually before he was even uh even uh
um a computer or a software engineer
and he was working at a
distantly sized or three big
construction company and he was already
like tinkering around with software and
data and trying to improve processes
even if that wasn't his role in the
company
um and yeah he'll uh
it will be uh guiding you guys through
uh most of the rest of this presentation
and
take it away
thank you
so
so I will start to make a little
difference from metadata and data
we can understand that metadata is a
information that we can get from the
data usually to to describe context
content over structure of a certain data
set
and data is the actual information and
contact the story in form of a file for
example
so some examples we can say that the
metadata in this table is presenting
for the columns and data type and some
description about the the columns
and the data is actually the information
that we can obtain from this
fields
we have this um
in our daily life from books as a table
of content summary
um
okay I don't know if it's a correct word
from a book and the actual data is the
content of the the whole book
another example is uh information
regarding a picture that we can see in
the place in that deal with some details
like the camera the lens the exposure
the outer and the date and something
more
to make a little contest
why this is important for us
um
in Big Data usually we have three layers
of data
bronze silver and gold at Metallica we
have the same concept
and
we have a little difference because we
don't use the data
as it is we correct with make a fetch
and we do a first ETL
to
to make a
identification of some fields and create
our own raw data
from this
bronze we have another
ETL
that we construct our Ona and our
oirs oirs means
observations insights and
recommendations
we analyze the data from
our clients we try to identify some
patterns
some deviations
and the
what is more or less considered as a
normally
we provide some information regarding
that
and for the final
stage for layer we have the gold with
also this last information from the
silver to use and populate the platform
if only you can go this
foreign
okay so I I just uh I just wanted to
talk briefly about this slide because uh
to provide some context about
where you know metadata fits in in what
we do and then how you know where the
Biden fit fits in and these things you
know essentially
um
uh uh so I said these little closer uh
like the tree Pages uh Philippe uh this
as a shown
um
so
the way uh the way we work is probably
important to provide the context way
people logic works is simply by uh
collecting
um
the digital footprint of a company so
via the tools we already used your your
kids your uh CRM Salesforce whatever
spot wherever you your
um your
so we collect that data and like just uh
you know the publicly the company public
data we're not like uh looking at
private metrics but the public that that
is public within the company right so we
collect that data and
um
and we analyzed sort of like the things
that are happening the events you know
you know
um to commit the opportunities one the
the the the accounts are closed with
tickets close wherever
um we collect all of that uh and then we
try to provide context and
uh we so we use this metadata uh I guess
we call it metadata but maybe uh like
for example
um
third so we use this metadata to provide
this context and like the human the
human metrics that are important to us
so we don't really care so much if a
ticket uh
has been closed it's more like okay what
did that uh represent for you uh
so this brown stage it's uh the piece
where we're collecting the state and
this metadata
um
and then I'm gonna just give you an
example of how what we're trying to
actually collect here uh so let's say uh
you know talking about a ticket
um
a ticket would have a different impact
on you depending on a few things right
so you know if it was a
urgent work like perhaps it was you know
you were working on something that uh
you know a
uh uh production hotfix or you know
something that uh
it was already passed the due date and
so on that was probably urgent work more
stressful work you know uh there's a was
it meaningful and fulfilling work that
fits your expertise right so I'm willing
to bet most folks here wouldn't
necessarily uh enjoy much uh tinkering
around with uh CSS maybe I don't know
but uh and they would much rather work
working with uh piping around maybe
potentially data and so on
um so is that work fulfilling in
meaningful for you uh it's your
expertise or maybe uh or are you working
on a feature that
there's no value on this for a
problematic customer but that that is
sort of things to try to collect from
the events and the objects and so on
like
they've found the data uh and metadata
uh that's how we try to kind of classify
those events in that way
so that we have those human metrics
right so that's what we sort of care
about here in order to provide our our
product I guess
um
so then I guess the the
so at this stage as this initial brand
stage we are like Philip mentioned we're
already doing some uh sort of
transformation so it's not not just the
collection but it's already doing some
transformation and some enrichment and
this is uh important probably because at
uh collection time like when you have
most of that context that we care about
um but then on there's a a an actual uh
transformation and enrichment space in
the Silver Stage where we are converting
that data I can do useful metrics for
example the save Factor but also you
know normalize or a auxiliary data sets
like normalized connections uh that
eventually become the graph which is
another component right in the product
um
is essentially okay now we have cleaned
up data and we have it's ready to become
consumed by the front end pieces whether
whether or you know all the
communication Channels with with the end
customers whether that is the browser or
slack or whatever
um
so now update is ready to begin by by
those places and is organized in a way
as allows slicing and dicing of the data
and not like drilling down in uh into
the insights we provide
um
so then uh where does python fits in
second I guess the interesting bit is
that python pretty much fits in in uh
all stages and um obviously we're
talking about data science and I'm
talking about spark and we're talking
about ice Park and all those things but
we also
um and
end up using it places that we didn't
initially invention Envision uh using
python for example for orchestration
orchestration of the pipelines and these
jobs like uh obviously the obvious
initial choices okay let's use something
like it was say the pipeline or
something along those lines uh but then
if you're out of you know
our
um
or sort of what where what our
requirements uh don't necessarily need
something like that uh and essentially
we we opt for in this case you know just
a few simple jobs uh that run in in the
dark container in uh in a kubernetes
cluster and just uh you know this and
then from there it just calls up a few
other services uh and tries to
um
synchronize the data between them uh
just simple Python scripts in this case
um the data collection as well is mostly
uh is similar we have
um
buy 10 jobs running in Docker uh Docker
containers uh
uh collecting data from all these
sources and transforming it and so on
and then storing it in the in the
database
um where we actually have your redshift
but it's not actually relative it's a
postgres database uh it used to be
relative but
again it's one of those things where you
make an initial Choice and then you say
okay we actually probably don't need
this let's kind of
uh tune it down a bit and went with
postgres
um
and then obviously I'm doing the data
transformation stage again we're
looking a few python jobs and then
obviously spark with
Pi spark and and so on
um yeah so now
Philip will probably take you guys into
the details of all these things I just
talked about
yeah thank you
so basically
uh in our product
we use essentially the spark
with some scriptures
python we use as a technology the Amazon
EMR ECS and S3 and
fds RGS and with postgres
in our
other analysis you know when we are
making the the studies from the data
also we use Essence essentially by spark
is more easy
with python
we use tools like jupitero Zeppelin
and for some bi we use the Amazon quick
site and the superset from a pass
also interesting very interesting
so
as ernan he was saying
he we have the
aggregation that fits more in the
bronzer number on stage we use basically
more the SQL Alchemy to to start and get
the data
some SD cards or a pythony's tip TP
client and some any other couple for
initial sentiment analysis from
text that we can collect from slack or
for comments and tickets comments in
Gators and so on so on
sorry
the orchestration that we use in some
Scripts
we use the moto3
with some credentials to use some of
these service from Amazon also the SQL
Alchemy
from the analysis I we just consider sun
no we don't put every everything but um
from the analysis used by spark num Pi
pandas Network series to create the
graphs
Network graphs and the plot we are not
broadly Weaver to show the
visualizations
um
here is an example from
aggregation API pipeline
in this case is a for Slack
we have already some metals here that we
showing that diagram
from the identification of the
participants or the
objects and in this case is the event we
can see here
here the
the event object and we consider the
contextual type as a conversation in
this case
but from the
collecting the participants we also had
more context
is the same for the objects in the
additional stats like for example amount
of words the sentiment of some messages
identification of
some objects like little tickets
uh to identify how the sentiment could
be regarding that ticket
um
and yeah
for the obsession we have here
from the our state factor I find the
example
we have some metals also we first
collect the data we run the script
regarding that data the script make a
video transformation
and use an
algorithm to to give us the score and we
store the final
data in our database
for the analysis here we can see main
main
by Spark
by Sparky is awesome because we can use
also SQL notation to create our tables
we just put a two bundles in the end
at the frame is awesome
and we can see also
here's some new platform plotly
expressed to show an Instagram
sorry
um
mainly we have here
a lot of sorts of that that we
collecting
there is a little more we just show here
some of them we can see slack Skype Zoom
outspot it guitar with lab
Google's and desk bambooth
8x8 Sage Microsoft and so on so we have
a lot more
um
machine learning models that we are
using for study and in production
we have
a service from the Amazon comprehend
also with any LT cap to obtain the
sentiment of
that regarding text
we are seeing also very much to forecast
time service in this case
to forecast the
how many connections or interactions
that we can obtain from the future on
the Ona
isolation first foreign
detections of anomalies
this one
was for now the the best one network
with our data that give us better scores
for our three Factor this is not a
conventional
work because we got the polynium to win
no meal regression using here
and they are 405 on that
uh also we are trying to use the graph
neural networks to
forecast new wages in the network
like if we can
predict if a person of the team of a
production engineering production could
connect with the sales or the customer
success
and from our platform
and
we got the Korean LP
to with our bot Flexi
that can we can use to write a normal
test to show us
some chart regarding some
team employee regarding activity or the
sentiment that I think you could have
really
yeah
um
did you write a graph neural network
software or are you using some some
particular
a graph
I I was interested in the the particular
GNN that you were using uh whether
vendor or
wrote it yourself could you say a little
bit more about your your GN
uh I can't say a lot
because it's in the initial State
um
we need to work a little more because
then
when I use on when we use a lot of notes
we got uh
from from this there because it's a he
can't
or at least for big companies when we
got more than 200 employees
uh
the the algorithm not work so well so
so is this is in in study we need to
look more on this
sorry I can answer uh more
can I continue
uh I guess Philip I I guess uh was
um sorry I don't know who was asking but
uh I guess question was also about which
Technologies in particular like
libraries are you
you didn't
in this case
yeah
yes thanks for answering my question
Philippe
thank you
we use the the latest regarding we use
from the network series Library
and um
we create
a little transformation
to
to identify
and with some epochs but
yeah yeah we need to work on further on
this
um
and yeah
we are finishing almost so our machine
learning models can you be used to help
the even resources and people things
more strategic well we find that we can
engagement
three identify factors that can
contribute or predict with which
employee
could be at risk
workforce planning
use the tenor performance promotional
mystery
some patterns and we can help to
planning this in the workforce decisions
The Source action planning
we can use
not only the Ona but is helpful to
identify
informal leaders
also with the Positive relations
positive sentimenting replying or
helping the the callings
some skills that can
help the team
Tanner
and something more
also for the Performance Management
what can contribute to y or low
performance
uh also we have talent acquisition of
learning and develop development like
how the programs or formations from the
company can provide
the necessary skills to help the
the company and the work to be done
compliance benefits from
company and so on and so on
you can speak Germany I think
if you want
or no okay I was
um
okay yeah so this is uh you know maybe
uh because there's always a lot of uh I
guess concerns about how we use the data
and what we do with it especially
because we're looking at someone so so
much
um
of of company data right so we're not
looking at personal data we're looking
at so much of a company that including
um public and emphasis on public slack
messages and so on
um
so uh there's a few uh points that we
always try to uh you know follow and um
uh uh include in everything that we do
uh with regards to the data so uh one uh
first point is uh fairness so
um
first off because we don't actually look
at personal data you know that that's
usually not uh going to be an issue but
you know
any sort of uh
data points that could lead to uh you
know discrimination or you know any sort
of bias we avoid
um
uh second point in this price obviously
we uh like all the data and this is
actually one of the reasons data like we
we have to analyze data
ad collection time or some of it like
for example sentiment and sentiment is
uh a very important
um not so much
for the the product now but of some of
this uh development that we're doing uh
ran our uh cylinder heavy development uh
in uh in a lot of aspects so in
sentiment tax sentiment is very
important here but we don't want to
um
we don't want to store any of that text
or any personal then file information so
we just want really uh you know these
metrics these human metrics uh so
we have to analyze uh we have to analyze
data at collection time and and
we avoid uh storing anything that we
don't have to
um so any sentiment uh analysis or uh
other source of enrichment
level and you know we have a source I
set a review realistics uh that we try
to collect with sort of things like
stress impact and so on
um all that is done as soon as we
collect the data to avoid boring
anything
um that you know can be a pricey issue
um and then uh the empowerment piece
here is important so we're not trying to
monitor uh and even though we talk about
the pharmacy more intense of uh
uh
you know engagement and performance of
uh the team as a whole more more so than
the individual employees uh you know
just
um have the employee or team member is
engaged within the team then he's going
to be
uh uh for most part as productive as the
rest teams are not necessarily looking
at productivity we're looking at
um you know again these uh sort of human
metrics so and the end goal is as well
is to empower the employees and to and
again kind of switching up uh the metric
and looking at safe factors more like
okay this is a metric of how
your team manager and your your
organization is performing uh
uh with uh is performing towards you so
uh you know
um
if they are keeping you happy that's
that's kind of what we're
looking for um and then um yeah
transparency uh you know we
we we're exposed to all the data we look
at and when I say look at this because
for the most part we only look at the
data take the note that we need and we
don't store it so we're not actually for
for the most part we're not actually
collecting anything we're just kind of
looking at it as you can as it happens
as things happen we look at it take our
notes
drop off so uh you know if one day uh
there's a massive leak uh if anything
you you'll see some some random numbers
that might not make a lot of sense that
there's no uh
company data stored on our servers uh
in many cases we're pretty transparent
about it and we uh everything is uh
pretty explicit okay we're gonna look at
um and replying to one of uh Mark's uh
uh questions yeah we're going to look at
for example Ken band uh borders Chrome
uh uh board uh
wherever he is your you track
if you connect obviously if you connect
it we're going to look at that and we
we're going to analyze that and we are
clear okay that is what we're going to
look like we're going to look at your
tickets your projects uh you know if you
have uh help this you know what's
happening on your help desk your
comments are going there we're going to
look at again uh sentiments because you
know there's
this textual communication is always
very important uh
to contextualize what's happening like
it's you know you can see someone's
getting
annoyed at I think attack it keeps
getting reopened for example things like
that
um
but and yeah we're we're clear about
uh what we're uh looking at
um
I think that's it for this one slide
okay and that is in the end the end I
guess so uh maybe I can answer uh the
other question from Mark I guess uh
if we can identify toxin environment or
toxic managers
um
so I guess the goal is uh let's say a
little bit of both
so we want to you know we want to
understand what's driving you Matt
what's burning you out is it the
environment is it the manager is but so
um
that's where we're uh what
so our goal ultimately so right now
um yeah we
uh we can kind of score the sentiment
and
we can work as us you know we can look
at you as an individual say
um you know if you're trending downwards
here if your sentiment is you know if
you're starting if we're starting to be
more uh negative in your comments and
your interactions uh or
unusual or if you're actually starting
to be more positive and if you're
actually you know you just started and
initially you were like okay it's serve
mix and now you're actually being very
positive and so on
um so we can look at you as an
individual uh we're not still at this
point at least at this point in time I'm
still not uh
uh looking at certain interactions so
and once we start digging more into the
interactions and actually incorporating
some of this into the graph in the
organization network analysis
uh then we can start identifying maybe
okay
where is the toxicity toxicity coming
from so okay is it the manager that is
uh uh you know uh
creating a blame culture I guess and you
know driving everyone mad or is just
the environment there is already
completely broken and you know and you
know everyone's just driving everyone's
mad and nobody wants to uh work with
anyone and so on so ultimately that is
the goal and then and so we're
incorporating more of this uh sentiment
analysis and stress factor factors and
so on into the connections
between the people and
and between the people and contextualize
for example also contextualized to for
example a particular project so you
could say
um projects or customers whatever
there's all sorts of contexts we can try
to provide so and you can say okay this
this one project you know if you have
let's say you have cures segmented in
multiple projects and you have
uh
people uh seem to be
fairly uh happy with it this other
projects actually
uh simply driving people mad even if
they are the same people so maybe
this is an indication of a problem here
is maybe all this project is laid out so
what's happening with this project what
are the customers and so on so that this
that's where probably so then we can
um
so so then we're actually sort of
entering the real realm of uh the root
cause analysis of uh the toxicity right
so that that's where also this uh in
this context is important and
connections between the people and
between what we call the objects which
is like the tickets the projects uh the
the the accounts customers right
um
that's a question on kind of the when I
picked through being a cold start
problem so when you start with the new
company there's kind of no precedent for
the volume of interactions or the tools
that they're using or the way they
communicate
um how do you how do you manage
onboarding a new client without that
wealth of data
um
yeah so most we uh
for us the most important things are
more um
the variations that necessarily uh
like various Advantage than necessarily
uh
you know the absolute value so uh it is
important that something is trending
upwards or downwards More Than This is
the value
um it is not a an easy problem this is
actually a problem we we we Face a lot
is how to provide value like right up
and back or customer you know comes in
connects these tools so we want to
provide some value like as soon as you
can exit tools
um
so here there's a dilemma obviously
because we have API access to the tools
that they connect like we can go and
look back uh
month if we want it but then that kind
of
that that kind of brings uh us to uh
maybe uh a privacy concern maybe maybe
the customer doesn't want us to go and
look that far back so we kind of tried
to balance maybe start start with uh
with one week that's how far back we
look back when we first connect your
tool and then try to provide some
insights some light inside Space of that
and then
um you know yours there will be we will
establish a baseline from there and then
we'll start looking at variations and
allows things are turning upwards or
downwards and uh go from there but yeah
it's difficult uh very difficult a
problem
yeah that makes sense
um I'm curious also
maybe it's more of a practical thing but
um you know as an employee if the
company says hey we're bringing in you
know this software layer to look over
your shoulder at every interaction you
have and evaluate it to determine you
know your your deepest secrets uh that
doesn't feel great have you
how do you address that or do you set up
to the company to figure out
from ad Tech where we do that to
everyone whether they work at a company
or not but um I'm still curious your
cake on it
yeah I I guess that that's why we we
tried to search about uh what we're
actually looking at and what is the
value we're trying to provide
um you know
uh
I guess to a point uh there's there's
always people that are there's always
managers that would try to use more uh
as a who do I need to fire rather than
who are people who are the ones uh that
need a vacation
um
I guess but the way we try to
uh provide the insights and to lay out
the data in the front end is uh
more focus on the positives on our
helping empowering uh
uh the employees
but but there's always also always that
concern of you know you're looking at my
data it's not uh you know your your uh
surveillance the big brother forever
there's always that concern it's
it's hard to
it's hard to to rap like for folks to
wrap their head around that but there's
a lot of
um
there's a lot of uh you know we have a
lot of marching material and so on to
help and that actually I think we have
here uh and I don't want to put her on
the spot but we have here Ashley we we
which actually
deals with that persons on a daily basis
so
yourself
let's see if I hi I've been in my little
Hall can you guys hear me
yes
cool
um yeah so just speaking about the
monitoring piece a little bit from a
customer success angle
um what we're really doing is we're
looking at data in an unbiased way as it
comes through the platform but you need
to humanize lens you know you need human
eyes and that data to really understand
what's going on essentially customer
success is embedded into the customer
team as an extension of that Org the
Departments and their teams and
employees and from there we really work
with them to not only help get them over
that hurdle of monitoring which we've
done for a couple of a couple customers
but we also work with them to serve as
process inefficiencies where we could
help them scale Roi and save time where
we could really help them connect their
team and offer a half day offer a full
day off to employees or teens that are
really working overtime on a new process
or project so it's more about humanizing
what we're doing and also reiterating
the fact that we we're never looking at
keystrokes login clicks we're not screen
recording you these are really important
things that people want to hear and
we're not doing that and we're also
really working on building out
enablement content that is external
facing people like you and our customers
so that they can really understand where
we're coming from
I hope that helps
yeah that's awesome
Ashley are you in Durham as well
no I'm in Colorado I'm in Denver it's
kind of cloudy today and over it's later
in the afternoon so it's getting kind of
dark okay
um yeah
um
oh yeah the the one question that I did
ask Matt
um when I when I was introducing myself
and recruiting him to to do a
presentation tonight
um was whether or not y'all used
um uh NLP or nlu and I saw that you're
using uh the nltk
package for symptomatic
analysis but do you also try to
understand the language it's that's
being used itself uh Beyond
sentiment analysis or does it kind of
stop with sentiment analysis at this
point
so we we actually so we actually have
two components uh
on um where we use uh NLP so we actually
have one mod that is uh maybe some sort
of poor men's chat GPT maybe where
people can ask sort of questions
um around the organization so it's very
it's very basic at the moment
[Music]
um
and yeah
and uh where it is mostly just uh
actually on that we're mostly using uh
Missing
most people using uh Amazon purposes for
that and then I would like to go on and
then the other component is the actual
sentimentality and yeah for mobile kind
of stops there so essentially we're just
looking at
um assignment and extracting while
there's also into it extraction and uh
we're actually looking at adding um you
know sentiment or empty and this is just
more again just for contextualizing
things so uh you know like to connect
dots and connect like subjects that
could be problematic within uh the
organization and so on not necessarily
you know not keyword uh monitoring uh
because that's uh and I understand that
also sometimes sounds like that it's not
the idea the idea here is more uh
connect topics and understand which
topics my uh me my
be problematic and maybe even connect
you know
[Music]
um
uh chat uh you know that are I ran a
particular customer so you know then
based on that sediment with that
customer you cannot say okay maybe this
customers
is part of the issue here
um so there's the lrp so
sorry my cinnamon and all is keyword
distraction and I think that it yeah so
those are the two uh
things where we use uh nltk for
um
maybe related to that you mentioned
early on something about
um and determining the the quality of
interactions between employees so not
just are they interacting but are they
working well together
um
is that
in my mind that sounds like uh NLP work
is that where that comes from or is it
more metadata about their interactions
yeah so so yeah so that's uh right the
sentiment and the uh you know that's
where the extraction also is because
um I like
so right now that's not Incorporated but
yeah you know one of the ideas is to
also kind of sort of weed out
um
because if you're looking at public
slides channels there's there's going to
gonna be a lot of goofing around and
sometimes there's going to be even
interactions that are going to be uh
false uh negatives or false positives
like uh you know you know people just
goofing around and making a joke and
someone will kind of pretend they're
reacting negatively and so on
um
so that's where kind of you know trying
to understand the subject of
conversation is important like okay are
you talking about work or are you just
goofing around so that's that's uh we're
important and then
um then if we can connect the dots and
the pieces and say okay uh you know
um
so we're not just looking at okay there
was this ticket then you are the
assignee we are looking at like actually
trying to understand within the other
tools who who have you worked with
to uh uh finish this ticket so then uh
based on the outcome we can you know uh
start start understanding
um
you know if you work well with that
person like okay so you know every time
um
person A and B work together in the city
so person a uh we're trying to take it
and it's the assignee and then person B
is the the reviewer on or just providing
some assistance in slack wherever you
know things work well together or
um or the other way around every time
person C comes in and like just try
everything turns into uh
a turn
when working C comes in so yeah that's
uh what you're looking at
thanks for the discussion on that are
there any other questions for the team
here
not I'll go ahead and end the recording
and turn it over to mark for uh
any lightning talk he said something
come in here
David Johnson asked I'm interested in
how you model the stay factor is that a
binary variable like probability of
leaving cune or scalar at the time until
leaving if it's binary why use
polynomial regression instead of
logistic regression
so I'm gonna
leave that one for Philippe if he's
still in are you still in Philippe
well our solution for This was um
a scaler
because
there is no Widener or black is Gray
and with the with the papers that we
read we saw that
in the beginning maybe the things are
too much light
but when the the time will pass
not so white we can dark for example the
Tanner we
is the one component consider that
that's that they say that after five
years the people tend to leave the
company
so the solution for the balvenian
regression was to consider that that
fact to have a spike
we feel the correct word
and that's when they
get on the five years but the maximum
score and then to become lower
micro having a hyperbole sorry for my
English
uh
and for the other components um it was
more or less the the same solution not
have a
soul
so
a binary solution because
there is or no one or zero
it can be in the middle so we consider
all with a scholar in all the components
if you just can answer the question
a
is more it's closer to your probability
of more like a sport from 0 to 100
um or zero to one I guess
um it's more like a score uh but it's
actually composed of several components
um you know yeah work-life balance for
example it's one of them like okay we're
actually looking at the times you're
active and maybe if you're kind of
jumping in outside of hours and that
sort of stuff and but then that also
like the the ratio of those sort of
things uh varies with uh other factors
like
uh your tenure uh potentially your age
because at some point you start looking
at the sort of things differently
um
and so on so uh but there are all those
factors behind there are a score and
then all of them converge into one
single uh score
yeah that's my complaints
um
all right well thanks uh hernani and
Philippe for awesome presentation and
and welcome us through everything you do
cool work looks like a lot of fun data
and really interesting problems you get
to work on
that's our pleasure please stay and
please stick around I know you're you're
on the uh other side of the the Atlantic
but uh stick around for my lightning
talk just
just bear with me it's a short one